if there's one thing that Call of Duty
is better known for than foul-mouthed
teenagers making unfounded sexual
allegations against your mother it's
zombie mode but this time around it
won't be the undead legions of Hitler's
army you'll be putting back in the
ground instead it's an experiment gone
horribly wrong by the sinister Atlas
corporation which is fortunate because
the only thing I hate more than a racist
bigoted zombie is a corporate shill
zombie if you want to survive the zombie
apocalypse here's what you'll need to
know now your first thought is probably
this is gonna be a cinch with an exosuit
strapped in my body right well kind of
first of all you've got to shoot and buy
your way to the XO room to even get an
exosuit in the first place and once you
have it there are enemies who can
disable your EXO abilities identifiable
by their electric glow kill these
bastards on sight barring these specific
baddies however the EXO - and jump are
gonna save your life an infinite number
of times in fact one of the only
strategies I've devised to prevent being
overrun in a bad scenario is to book it
outside circle strafe to cut the zombies
into a group and unload as many shotgun
shells and contact grenades as I can
while jumping around and jetpacking my
way to safety and whatever you do do not
get cornered there's a handful of other
special enemies you'll encounter as well
such as waves of dogs that occasionally
pop up and perhaps the most nefarious of
all those green cloud emitting zombies
that infect you giving you 60 seconds to
get to the decontamination center before
you go blind and die at the same time
which is coincidentally my worst fear
don't forget that the decontamination
center has a cool-down tube so wait for
your buddies to hop in before showering
off you'll begin each game outside on
the opposite end of the map from your
beloved exosuit so spend the first few
rounds banking points before you even
open any doors grab the semi-auto rifle
and possibly the Bulldog shock and as
soon as you can afford bolt and try to
maximize your points with headshots and
knife kills while the hordes are still
manageably sized this combo of a
powerful close-range weapon and a more
automatic accurate boomstick should be a
constant in your arsenal once you've
taken down the first few rounds start
making your way toward the XO room there
are huge red signs with arrows to guide
you so no matter which route you take
you'll probably end up there eventually
remember that every upgraded station and
unlockable including the exosuits
housing requires you to hit the switch
on a power breaker in the same area so
don't rush in there trying to pull off a
smash-and-grab
take your time and plot your approach or
try to grab an exosuit between rounds
it's also worth noting that if you die
and your teammates complete the round
you're gonna respawn with Noah
so suit and no weapons so try to plot
your approach to regaining an exosuit
quickly once you're suited up a variety
of EXO upgraded stations become
available you'll want to take a good
hard look at the map on the loading
screen before you even begin to learn
their locations but give it a few good
rounds and you'll become familiar soon
enough all the EXO upgrades have their
place but exit reload is probably going
to be the most useful of the bunch for
you you're gonna be pissing through
clips magazines and shells like you're
getting paid to do so so cut down on
time between rounds with this perk to
ensure your survival seriously if anyone
can make it pass round 20 without this
perk send me a screenshot because you
might be superhuman the other EXO
abilities are all useful in their own
right
EXO medic speeds up your revival of
friends or if you're playing solo it
gives you one self revive per purchase
EXO soldier is a duplicate of the
gung-ho perk and will allow you to use
your weapon while sprinting EXO health
increases your health yeah they pay me
to figure this [ __ ] out and finally EXO
slam and locks our aerial assault
ability some of the more minor things to
know don't forget to grab the 1 to 200
credit bonus from the green terminals
scattered throughout the level as you go
and don't forget about the trash chute
in the exit room and never really
remember to use it in any sort of a bad
scenario but it could save your life in
a pinch also the security system can be
activated by a razor shape to power up
or a variety of terminals and will
activate violently slamming doors a
series of floor lasers and other traps
but watch yourself around these hazards
because they can damage you too
upgrading your grenades to contact
grenades is insanely useful as you can
just pop one into a crowd and clear a
room without having to cook your
explosives orbital drops are also
essential as you'll occasionally be
gifted a turret a drone or a camo
powerup from the sky but these are
self-explanatory finally and I promise
you this is a biggie leave one zombie
alive at the end of every round if at
all possible
this will give you the freedom to reload
buy new weapons upgrade purchase perks
regroup and find a good position to hold
off the next horde of zombies if you
finish the round and then head off to
handle these tasks as the next horde
comes in you're gonna find yourself in a
hairy situation in short order that's
the gist of EXO zombie mode but there's
still weapon upgrades in the mystery
boxes successor the 3d printer to cover
so stay tuned the game spot for all your
undead updates on Call of Duty now
excuse me while I shower all this blood
and pus off oh yeah that's good
decontamination